una victoria bastante importante Rafael
Warner gana con más de un millón 800 mil
votos Tres puntos porcentuales de
diferencia contra el aspirante
republicano
y esto significa pues bastante para el
presidente Joe primero porque su
vicepresidenta kamala Harris Pues no va
a tener que estar yendo al congreso
constantemente a dar su voto de
desempate sino que los comités pues van
a poder aprobar rápidamente los
proyectos de ley y sobre todo las
nominaciones hay muchos nombramientos
que están
atascados en este momento en los comités
precisamente porque no se tenía la
mayoría de asientos en el senado además
significa también para el presidente
pues una ficha de Victoria una carta que
pueda presentar en las elecciones del
2024 de como su partido aunque se haya
criticado su administración gana en la
en las elecciones de mitad de término un
escaño una silla bastante importante
como la de Georgia para Trump significa
sin embargo otra derrota más electoral y
esto ha sido y esto ha sido bastante
bastante fuerte para el partido
republicano porque pues empieza a
fragmentar empiezan muchos republicanos
a cuestionar el verdadero poder que
tiene chompa a nivel nacional y muchos
dicen ya que para poder empezar a ganar
a nivel nacional y a nivel Estatal pues
hay que empezar a desligarse de la
figura de Donald Trump sobre todo en
estados que ya son púrpura y no rojos
como